each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
all right okay so everyone has some food
everyone has some food hopefully and
some drinks you can keep eating and you
can talking but want to make sure you
guys are fed hopefully and happy and you
know make it through the rest of this
evening and make sure you show up for
tomorrow morning so not too late not too
late tonight but you know with this is
something new we're trying this just
here to have some of the talks in the
evening along with the dinner so
appreciate your feedback after this I'm
how wellick is I want to have three
talks this evening following dr.
cornstalk will have a to from actually
from Microsoft people actually krills
not going to be coming but it'll be
Marvin themer will be actually doing the
hpc talk and then savas will be doing
the work of it he actually did a
Newcastle previously to coming to
Microsoft and talk to them about that
but I'd like to actually introduce first
dr. Milton corn from NIH assistant
director there and it's going to give us
some info on what's going on in NIH so
appreciate it
I'm competing with mussels and beer here
I don't think that's going to be too
successful but unlike some of the others
here in fact unlike all the others here
I have nothing actually to to show you
as an accomplishment i am from the
National Library of Medicine and I think
some of the things we did have been
mentioned here today genbank umls we
funded gully burns and other things but
the idea here is not to tell good things
that the NIH is done but to tell you
that we really need the type of
expertise that I think the people who
are attending this workshop actually are
able to offer I think the type of
science that's done by the National
Institutes of Health biology and
medicine as is actually coming up
against the wall and unless we embrace
computation as a serious and I think
probably permanent collaboration we're
going to have a lot of Brownian movement
over the next few years it hasn't always
been my fab I think biology was perhaps
the last of the sciences to actually put
much credence and computation when I
first came to NIH in the early 90s I
think the only Institute that had any
interest in computation was the National
Library of Medicine actually which was
using it for Republic and things of that
sort the genome made the difference is I
think most people know suddenly the
presence of enormous and large datasets
got people's attention and then in the
late 90s there was a conversion on the
road to Damascus so to speak and now
there's a great deal of activity a great
deal of interest and I think there are a
number of people who want to collaborate
to bring computation and what they're
doing but I think there's a good bit of
uncertainty about how to do it and on
the other hand
there's a lot of uncertainty on the part
of people who are computationally
sophisticated about just what on I NIH
wants and and whether in fact it's worth
while working with with the Institute's
and how to go about it if one does it so
my relatively brief remarks here will be
to give you a little a primer on some
things that are happening with us and in
the hope that some of you will have
enough interest in it to try to pursue
sue this further I'm not you've heard
plenty of examples of computation in
medicine there aren't nearly as many as
I wish they were you heard some this
afternoon I've just listed a few here
it's not an exhaustive list but I don't
want to pretend that this is a small
sample out of tens of thousands because
we simply have not been taking advantage
of of computation these are some which
we help support we collectively the
National Institutes of Health probably
in fairly recent years and I think it's
just the beginning of what is going to
be a really large stream of important
findings of just a few definitions
because there isn't much congruence on
what bioinformatics and computational
biology mean and we we didn't probably
get it right either in the sense that we
have the gold standard we were so as a
group unsophisticated about the field
that a committee was actually formed in
the late nineties actly 1999 to see if
we could arrive at some definition about
what bioinformatics and computational
biology really are supposed to mean his
terms and I'm simply going to tell you
what the NIH committee came up with not
because it agrees with what you're doing
but if you're going to be looking at NIH
announcements and so on it's probably
good to keep in mind what these
definitions were this one is probably
not in the mainstream but it's
relatively easy because
boiled down if you look at the second
bullet its it basically says that
computational biology is is modeling and
everything else is bioinformatics in
practice the terms are not used with any
particular semantic precision they are
either in one does hear biomedical
computing digital biology and all the
phrases that you probably hear at your
own organizations as well but this is
the the Holy Writ and in terms of the
official jargon a little bit about NIH
most of you probably know this but it's
quite important for anyone who's
interested in working on NIH projects or
in trying to get some funding for
projects from the NIH that there isn't
any NIH there is a big campus we have a
lot of people who are very friendly with
each other but in fact we have 27
semi-autonomous Institute's we have a
director and he is in fact highly
respected and a very important person
for all of us but actually each of the
Institute's has its own budget besides
what its own research agenda is
announces its own programs and makes its
own funding decisions which is makes
life difficult for people who would like
to know what's going on in terms of
funding opportunities because it's not
easy to know what 27 different
organizations have out there at any
given time for computational purposes
we've been dividing the the Institute's
actually into two major categories of
which the second so far has been doing
most of the computational funding the
first one are they the ones that have a
disease or a theme of some kind the
categorical Institute's cancer heart
Texas disease and so on the so-called
cross-cutting Institute's the national
library and the other acronyms here is a
much smaller number
rather significant amount of funds
available and they're considered the
ones who are interested in more
interested in computation have come up
with a great deal more money for this
and at the moment are probably providing
most of the computational infrastructure
that's being built for biomedical
projects some jargon about the NIH
probably the two biggest buzz words
under which computational projects are
subsumed are bisti was the first one
it's now a frozen epithet there probably
aren't six people on the campus know
where two stands for anymore now you
know briefly because I'm putting it here
but initially was a white paper for the
director of the NIH prepared by bus teen
and and Smarr in 1998 when Harold Varmus
was here and it really was the the call
for the revolution I think the place was
a little sneak sleepy about computers
until that paper came along and there's
been a lot of activity since then
because computation doesn't really
belong to one institute rather than the
other we've need some needed some
organizational changes to try to react
for this and this tea is now the name of
a app an NIH Center which attempts to
coordinate and keep track of
computational projects it's housed in
the institute for general medical
sciences but in fact it coordinates
activities of a number of Institute's it
actually issues some announcements for
projects that is interested in and it
has its own website I've listed that
here because for anyone who would like
to take a quick look at one-stop
shopping for what actually might be
available in in terms of funding or
support for projects this is probably
the single best site
the road map is the other buzzword I
haven't heard it here today but it is
fairly well-known the had a spread in
science news weekend and so on it
actually was an initiative of the
current NIH director Elias there hunie
and I think he recognized the 27
autonomous Institute's can get a lot
done but there are a number of things
that fall between the cracks and he was
interested in research issues that
simply didn't fit the mission statement
of any of the 27 institutes we have and
he came up with a series of projects and
came up with some funds for them and he
is funding them in a number of different
areas but the main themes really had to
do with among other things of importance
here is new ways of doing doing science
and he was particularly focused on the
need for interdisciplinary projects in
which biomedical scientists and
computational scientists as well as
social scientists and people from other
fields would start working together I
think there's a belief probably a
minority belief but a belief that many
of us have which is the team science of
some kind is probably where an awful lot
of the important results are going to
come from in the future in general while
there are a lot of road map projects
computation is a very important part of
almost all of them and the
interdisciplinary issue is considered so
important that it has a number of
training programs for we ourselves
didn't think that most of the biologists
that we were funding and physicians
actually were very good at team science
and many of them are not interested in
it and we thought that it probably would
take some nurturing to try to see
whether
disciplinary teams would in fact be
successful and could make a go of it and
we don't know the result of that as yet
some centers will be funded this year
specifically for interdisciplinary
science we've just finished blending
seven national centers for biomedical
computing across the country and each
one of these had to as an element of the
competition indicate which computer
scientists and which biologists and
which clinical researchers would be
involved in doing this and how they will
interact and so on it's all a very
interesting rich mixture that we're
working with and I think we'll probably
know more in another four or five years
about whether we're actually able to
foster facilitate a collaboration of
this sort we know it has to be done and
it may be that we haven't picked the
best way of doing it but we rather
thought that just waiting for life to
take its course would take much too long
because of the normal of an inertia of
any scientist is comfortable with what
he's doing it's worked for him since
bacon who was mentioned earlier today
and he probably thinks it'll certainly
last out of his career but in fact we
think it will this is another website
and it's another interesting source of
funding for a rather interesting group
of projects that have heavy
computational component I didn't hear
systems biology mentioned here today I
think probably most of you have heard
about it I think it's in a conceptually
a very exciting it's not possible to do
without an enormous contribution and
collaboration with computational
specialists and I think it has the
intellectual Lee exciting idea that
biology may for the
first time be able to compliment 500
years of reductionist science with
looking at systems we haven't been able
to do much of that all of you know that
there are almost no general laws in
biology certainly very few that can be
captured in mathematics and a very few
that are predictive of anything and i
think the successes of reductive science
genome is simply one example of that are
marvelous but i think people are now
starting to look at what happens when
you put systems together how do they
operate and so on i don't think anyone
with the IQ the safety pin thinks that
looking at all the elements of the cell
gives the faintest indication of how the
cell works reproduces or anything else
this has two major components in the in
the places where this is being tried
there's an experimental arm because we
really don't know many of the subsystems
that are involved in cells as one
example and then the second attempt will
be to try to actually get some
mathematical modeling with the hopes
that we not only can capture at least
the rough approximations of what's going
on but that will be able to use them for
predictive purposes I think it's very
exciting I think the phrase is used much
more often than it's understood and
probably a Google hit on that will give
you a number of different explanations
of it but I think if there's any one
concept that carries with it a need to
have biomedical scientists and
computational people work together it's
certainly systems biology it's not
possible without both of them being
heavily involved with this and then the
last sort of buzz phrase that's of great
importance to us and also care
is with it an implication of major
computational involvement is
translational research the genome and
which is simply a placeholder is a term
for all the other omics I think every
literate American or every literate
person in at least in in the West knows
that the genome actually was a was a
fine achievement but it didn't explain a
great deal and that to actually get it
to have some meaning for health I mean
this is the National Institutes of
Health after all the genome is not going
to be by itself make a huge contribution
and as Francis Collins has said by
genomics now he means proteomics
metabolomics other omics and so on which
are turning out to be unbelievably
complex are very difficult to work with
but that's the way that's what's making
life happen and this is where the work
is going to be done we also it won't
surprise you we're a federal agency and
the Congress while it is it is it is
happy to congratulate us for the genome
I really wants to know what we're doing
is useful in the intensive care unit and
from time to time we need to be reminded
of that actually but there's a lot of
effort going into translational research
now the roadmap alone is doing it it's
very hard to do this but what it really
means is to try to take basic science
genome proteomics and so on and see what
this can do for the help of the public
what it can do for clinical medicine
these are just some of the exam as a
matter of fact these are some of the
low-hanging fruit the people are working
at these are designer drugs not
medically designer drugs early markers
of disease predicting life events
micro arrays of dimension here today
they're being done all over the place
this microarray data are probably
sitting in every major Medical Center
with people wondering what to do with it
actually but in in general making this
happen as it is a fascinating and
extraordinarily important milestone I
think for biology because it not only
has serious and very difficult
computational problems translational
research but it introduces things that
were also brought up here today social
issues of privacy human use issues
whether we'll be able in fact to use
electronic medical records for
scientific purposes it's really tied
into the fabric of the culture so we
have an interesting example of an
unrivaled opportunity to make enormous
strides in healing but to do this will
not only be difficult for science it's
going to be difficult for computation
and it will be difficult for the culture
and the social system to work it out I
don't know how this will go it may be
that it will be very difficult to take
full advantage of all of this of privacy
concerns in genuine and they carry quite
a lot of weight on the hill and we'll
have to just see how this is just
getting genomic data on people our
medical centers is already creating
extraordinary difficulties in
safeguarding the data for reasons that
all of us would have sympathy for now if
you were interested in whether you had
anything that we might want I you can
look at those websites that I showed you
there are other ways too I think drill
down and get a little more detailed
information that you can really find out
what we're funding now
it may well be that you will look at
what we're funding and think we really
don't know what we're doing but it
doesn't matter that's what it is and at
least at the moment so i think is the
first cut you can do some of the things
i'm suggesting here just to get a look
at it probably a little bit more useful
than fiddling with pubmed would be the
third bullet here if you in fact go to
the bisti website is URL i have here
it'll show you what actually got funded
by all these after all these
announcements that we put out and it
doesn't mean you're limited to that but
i think it'll give you some idea of the
Alpha and Omega where we've been going
so far I think in fact you'll find that
it's rather a broad spread of things and
of course if you do look at it you not
only will see the topics that have been
covered but it will give you some idea
of what people have been funded and
it'll give you a chance to look at and
say they gave money to him I can't
believe that all right here are some I'm
not going to explain these you can you
read that red yes this is just to have
you looked at the titles because they're
open now these are all competitions that
are open now and are soliciting
applications what's underneath the hood
in each of these is of course varied and
you'd have to read the announcement to
see if there's anything there the
scratches you're rich but I think in
general you can see it's fairly broad
would be hard to think of somebody who
with a great computational expertise who
couldn't find a place here where where
he's needed just take a look at them
it's not all genomics up it's very happy
to hear hear that there was a lot of
interest in imaging which is a difficult
and very interesting field of its own
heterogeneous data sources the problem
for everybody everywhere the last one is
an example of something that's
increasing more and more
are we're partnering more and more with
the national science foundation in fact
with do e on this particular one and
some of you probably were involved in
this but this one because it just
finished the first round a few months
ago now those were for individuals these
you're sitting here or you and a
co-worker and you can go apply for these
I'd like to separate out the ones where
you really can become a collaborator
with people and these are the centers
and we have had a spate of centers being
funded in the last few years and I as
simply one and but there are others too
I'm not sure how good a idea centers are
there an easy way to spend money they're
attractive on a blackboard how well they
work in actuality is quite variable we
have a long experience with cancer
centers and some of them have been
brilliant and some of the member modess
trian and we're hoping that that these
will all be brilliant or at least middle
of the road every single one of these
from the get-go had to have large
computational components and in terms of
the budget involved I say of the sums
given to these centers and they're quite
large for NIH and some of them they vary
between 2271 case 12 million dollars a
year which is not chump change and 25 to
40 percent of the budget had to go for
computational purposes so there are
opportunities in these things the reason
I bring this up is that if you really
don't know how to get going but you're
at it one at a place that has one of
these centers do you have a ready-made
opportunity to go and introduce yourself
to some people because otherwise there's
no good dating bureau for how you mean
partners with whom the work i'll touch
on that when i finish what will be in a
moment moment there's two more on this
slide that I really want to tell you
about except that I've been focusing on
things we're soliciting you don't need
to wait for that the majority of the
projects we do fund traditionally are
unsolicited investigator originated
applications and there's no reason why a
computational specialist with a good
idea can't do that too it's not
necessary to wait for an invitation you
can send an unsolicited application and
if you do so your success rate actually
historically is it is about as good as
the people who do apply our success rate
is certainly a lot better than it is for
NSF at the moment for budget reasons and
other reasons we generally try to stay
in the neighborhood of twenty percent
success rate plus or minus a little
we're not that this year we're probably
closer to at the National Library we're
at nine percent some of the other
institutes are in the teens I think
that's temporary having to do with a
doubling of the budget and I think in
general the success rate for
applications will be in the high teens
or twenty percent but you might like to
see it better but it does mean that
there's a rate there's a reasonable
chance and if you send a revised
application which we permit to revise
the applications sess rate goes up
closer to 28 or 30 percent it's not bad
odds I don't think anyone in this room
thinks one hundred percent of the
applications really deserved a federal
funding I do think though that if you
not reply if you're not applying with
solicitation a talk to somebody it's a
lot of work to prepare an application a
lot more work than for an NSF
application and
I try to find an institute and a program
contact you can talk to and say you know
what I'd like to do this send them an
email a column and say what do you think
got any chance my last URL on this slide
actually has a list of the computational
contacts for every one of the
Institute's i'm going to post this on
our website so you may not need the rest
of this talk but if you have any
interest in any of the urls you'll be
able to pick them up later and then
another way I think that you can get
some information that might be of
interest is who's doing the reviewing
for computational projects and I don't
want to go the whole ten steps to the
review group but you should know that
unlike other agencies we have a
different group that does the of the
reviewing the Institute's don't usually
do their own reviewing and if you go to
csr the Center for scientific review you
can find out all the review group some
of them have computation in their name
and if you you're all very experienced
with with browsers and web sites and if
you drill around a little bit you'll get
some idea of who what people are being
selected to to do the reviewing and
certainly help you with trying to jockey
around which review group your your
application will go to I'm not going to
tell you how to do that here but it's
not hard with a little coaching if
you've never written a grant to the NIH
talk to somebody who has NSF experience
is not particularly useful and I'm going
to repeat some things in closing here
that I think you heard from others today
I mean this is a very intelligent group
of people I plea please don't think that
because you know how to apply your
technique
some subset of data you've worked on
that the biologists are a group of not
particularly bright people sitting there
in a pool of data and all they need is
your tech technique because it won't
work and it will look like a very
unsophisticated application as as was
said by someone else you have to look as
if you know something about the biology
domain and if you haven't done it before
get somebody from the field even a
brilliant unsolicited application from a
computer person throws great skepticism
by the NIH review groups if there's no
physician or biologist involved and this
is my last one really suppose you want
to do this and you don't know how to
find somebody these are just some things
you can try if you're at a Medical
Center the direct response and research
might might tell you who is working in
the field you're looking at the others
speak for themselves i'm not going to go
over these these bullets but the last
one maybe deserves a little bit of
information it's not too good to do most
of the project on your own and then try
to find somebody who will sort of be a
fig leaf for you it works on both sides
that you should work the partnership I
should start early in the project and
then lastly this is my name if I've gone
over something semi incoherently but you
have any interest in it by all means
email me and then the material in this
talk we will put it up on our website
which is actually the National Library
of Medicine website the extramural
program bulletin and I really appreciate
your attention during dinner that must
be very hard to do thank you
what take this off